while only one of this weekend's top 10
non animated movies was directed by a
woman and fewer than half of them are
led by female actors the newest study
from USC's Annenberg School for
Communication and journalism examines
equality in the film industry
researchers looked at 900 movies and
more than 39,000 characters over the
past decade to measure the changes in
diversity first on CBS this morning
professor stacy smith a co researcher of
the study is with us good morning
professor good to see you
good morning it's great to be here so
break this study down for us yeah well
we look at the top 100 films every year
every speaking character from someone
who utters one word all the way through
the protagonist and we look at a variety
of characteristics gender race ethnicity
LGBT and characters with disabilities so
you've been doing the study since 2007
what have you found when you look at
those numbers in terms of diversity well
that's a great question flag first we
see that the needle is not moving for
females on-screen and film across more
than 39,000 speaking characters less
than a third of all on-screen roles go
to girls and women that clocks in at a
gender ratio two point three males to
everyone female
we also see an epidemic of
intersectional invisibility we look at
how many films of the top 100 last year
are missing different groups over forty
five don't feature a single female black
speaking character on screen sixty six
completely devoid of Asian females 72
don't feature one talking latina and
over 90 completely erased the LGBT
community so at USC Annenberg we like to
say we don't have a diversity problem we
actually have an inclusion crisis on
screen and behind the camera so well
there were more executives with more
diversity in the offices in Hollywood
well we've examined that and our
Seminole card study in February of 2016
and we see that few women are at the
upper echelon of power what we have
found is that when there's a female in
the director's chair from some of the
other work that we've done with short
films and independent features you see
more girls and women on screen more
female leads more women 40 and above
more racial and ethnic diversity
we need more feet
directors to be calling the shots behind
the camp and you see people like Reese
Witherspoon you know who's my now
producer and making lots of project and
using lots of women right but we need
women in that key leadership positions
directors as a producer we also need
female directors calling the shots
because that's the key like patty
Jenkins and Wonder Woman recently or
Kathryn Bigelow coming up with Detroit's
what's inhibiting the studios from this
inclusion you talked about
well there's exclusionary hiring
practices I mean when only 4.2 percent
last year 4.1 percent over 900 films one
thousand and six directors four point
two percent feature women we really see
that there's exclusion when it comes to
who's getting to call the shots only
three african-american women have
directed across the last 900 films to
Asian women in one latina they're not
getting the opportunity and our findings
present a pretty condemning portrait of
exclusionary and discriminatory hiring
practices that though the question is
why they not hiring well if in fact
there were what what factors would cause
them to do more more successful films of
a certain kind or what absolutely well
there is an economic argument and often
they link the gender of the lead
character the race and ethnicity of the
lead character with the director if only
34 films feature a female leader Colie
this gives female directors fewer
opportunities out of the top 100 of last
year women aren't on consideration list
we asked 59 executives how many top of
mind directors could they think of the
mode was zero
the average was three people aren't
recalling female directors to consider
them across the range of these top
directing jobs is there also just a
shortage of good scripts and good
opportunities I mean it's there's a
difference I guess there in the
selection versus the opportunity well I
think that's a great great question
hidden figures is a perfect example
there are amazing stories out there to
be told and there's the financial
prowess of female driven content it's
the lack of decision-making and
Greenlining ability of who says these
stories can move through so you think a
film's success like hidden figures will
make a difference it should but often it
doesn't by looking at our data
hundred films urine and you're out no
change but even if a film like Wonder
Woman patty Jenkins is making so much
money doesn't it always come down to
dollars and cents it should when half of
the box-office audience is women 49%
people of color you would think why are
we leaving money on the table Moana
hidden figure Wonder Woman the list goes
on and on girl's trip two weekends ago
absolutely Stacy Smith thank you it was
great to be here